me and the others that I dance with
nobody I don't think anybody really knew
she was pregnant she hid it very very
well she just hit it with layers and
nobody really suspected anything
at least with me personally I had no
intonation at all of her pregnancy and I
don't know there's just such a big
distance between her and the dancer for
me to get a good look at her especially
since I'm focusing so much on
my performance I wasn't necessarily like
looking at her and the TV and stuff so I
never I never saw above until
not even the day up
[Music]
[Applause]
we had about two weeks worth of
rehearsals and it was an average of
eight hours rehearsing per day okay we
rehearsed with her about three or four
times so most of our rehearsals weren't
actually with her she would wear like
big coats or those Fenty sweatshirt sets
and so I didn't see anything especially
since she's on the platforms a lot and
probably my favorite one that she's
wearing um it was like a old brown Fenty
tracksuit and then she put a huge baby
blue fur coat over that and I just love
like brown and baby blue
and little did we know she was covering
up her pregnancy we just thought like oh
that's wrong this is how she dresses
um
for the rest of the rehearsals she was
wearing all red as if we were doing the
real thing so all red big layers was
pretty much the theme she can go from
dressing like walking around bikini and
heels to the next day a huge like
oversized coat and pants like that's the
normal for her and it's cold outside so
I don't think anyone really suspected it
but now that she showed it we were all
confused watching it during the real
thing when she went up there and was
showing her stomach we were like wait
because she wore the same outfit for one
of the dress rehearsals but it was
zippered up but this time she had her
stomach exposed
[Music]
so during the performance I did not see
her pregnancy at all just because I was
just so focused on making sure that I
was performing and getting rid of my
nerves and just trying to kill it and I
didn't want to distract myself in front
of like National Television so no I
never never saw her rub her belly until
afterwards I had to re-watch the
performance on YouTube to realize oh my
gosh she does have a problem I've never
I never realized that and even then I
was still defending her till the end
until it was officially announced by her
later on that day so I feel like we were
all kind of confused like
because it seemed like she was pregnant
but then we didn't want to assume that
she wasn't pregnant and being rude which
a lot of people did
so it was just really interesting
shocking I'm kind of glad she didn't
tell anybody
because I feel like some people would
have exposed it and then I finally saw
what everybody was talking about because
I was getting texts as well with people
asking me is Rihanna pregnant and I was
like you just be asking if women are
pregnant I thought that something I
thought that's an unspoken rule we all
know but I went back watched the YouTube
video I was
on the verge I didn't know yet and so I
was like I'm just gonna wait until she
announces it into the news analysis it
and announces it and later on that night
it was officially announced like soon
after and I was like okay so
she is pregnant sorry for everybody that
I yelled at for assuming y'all were body
shaving I don't know
[Music]
honestly I'm probably most impressed
that she did all of that while she was
pregnant especially being on the
platforms because the platforms were
like if you look really closely they
were super shaky they were very like
lifted very high into the air and held
together by a little harness and the way
she did all that multiple times while
she was pregnant the entire time and she
still killed it and she still like
stayed super sweet to everybody I think
that was pretty amazing and she was
killing the dance moves especially like
that whole car with her on the boxes
jumping into a little booty shake and
everything that's another reason why I
didn't think she's pregnant because I
thought she was killing those dances and
so she never she never let her pregnancy
get in the way of her stamina and
especially with her being on those
platforms going all the way in the air
like who would have thought pregnant
woman would be that high up in the air I
think it was like 60 feet in the air
that's the third reason why I didn't
think she was pregnant but here she is
just proving us all wrong in the most
amazing ways
[Music]